Michael
right he's going to do the tanahanker
with his hands
push them fingers out
all right
since he used to say
that
he's got to be it's got to hold water
so you'll see it's by pushing your
fingers that won't help because of uh
you've still got the gaps
so that's when we say Tana Hank is
really difficult
it seems simple you know what I don't
know why I'm doing this really why the
sense he keeps saying it's so important
he's got to make you'll notice beside
her sense you know look at the videos he
doesn't have flat hands he has them
slightly up
but in this part in this part
so
poor Michael's work trying to work out
all angles and how he makes this pull
but there is a bit of water in there now
move that out a little bit right so so
you've got to not cramp your hand you've
got to have your hand open but as you
as you do that you see I don't know if
you can see it but I'm making
a pool
all right so this look this won't take
water will it
this
takes water
so oh
I don't often
I don't often go to that sort of bother
with them playing games or sale or do
anything but I just want to show you
what how difficult Hannah hinker is
um
so you're coming here this shape this
shape here I don't know if you can see
that those who can see the pole the pole
is made
I don't go here and then sort of start
to
do this
so here I go one
coal is now made and I come here
all right you see both hands they would
hold they would hold water
all right something I've never taught
before but I keep seeing lots of a
different kind of hangers and people
either do that or do that
but what you're looking for is a pole
without tension
a pole that is created without tension
all right so we'll try a little more and
I'd just like you to look at it because
you know you might sort of say well I
think that's right if I say to you will
it hold water
I don't know why I sent you he didn't
offer say it very often but he he did
one day said
that this should be able to hold water
okay